uh it's great to be here that's quite a
quite an impressive um introduction I
appreciate that uh it's really sort of a
pleasure and an honor to be here uh
presenting uh to the community that uh I
learned so much from uh it's really kind
of a highlight in my so far short career
so I'm Matthew Romaine if you want to
follow me on Twitter uh it's at Kwanzaa
um so since we're doing a language
related startup uh I usually like to
start my presentations with sort of a
word of the day uh and so today I chose
umashi which maybe some of you have
heard uh the jat when Japan was bidding
for the 2020 Olympics uh this word was
mentioned a number of times and it
basically means a spirit of helpless
selfless Hospitality uh and so if you've
been to Japan maybe some of you
experienced a really rich service
culture that's there
um can you raise your hand if you've
visited or been to Japan before
wow awesome okay cool oh hey Kenji
um see some familiar faces so when uh Dr
Dasher asked me to speak uh today
um he asked me a number of interesting
questions that he wanted me to cover uh
so I'm going to try my best to uh try
and cover these
um throughout the presentation but as I
before I get into the details of gengo I
think it's kind of important to
understand sort of my background and
where I came from uh and so just indulge
me a little bit as I share a little bit
about my sort of upbringing
so I'm actually half Japanese half
American I was born in Boston but I grew
up in Japan and as you heard a little
earlier I studied computer science and
music theory at Brown and here at
Stanford was more focused on the music
side
which led to an opportunity at Sony
where I did a lot of Audio Research and
um in a research group there and sort of
mixing internet audio streaming
and uh just out of curiosity uh is
anyone want to take a guess what how
much my first paycheck was for the first
month I was in Sony so this is a
Stanford Masters student making
anyone want to guess
2 000. very close 2 500 a month so it
seems kind of low but you know of course
it came with a lot of benefits there was
subsidized housing there was
Transportation it was covered um and
Japan is one of the best Healthcare
infrastructures in the world and so uh
that was sort of the beginning and I
kind of rationalized moving back to
Japan for a couple reasons
one was I wanted to sort of get back to
my roots
um and be with my family that was out
there uh I wanted to experience working
in a Japanese company
which I figured I'd rather do earlier on
when the pay was not as important as as
the experience
so and I figured I'd be there for a
couple years and probably come back to
the U.S
so despite being a a global company uh
the housing wasn't so Global so this is
my room kind of small uh in fact the
bathroom uh was so small when I sat on
the toilet I couldn't close the door
because my my legs were so long
so I stayed there for a couple months I
ended up moving to a slightly larger
apartment uh
but the the opportunities and the
experience that that Sony provided were
really fantastic and even though I was
hired as an engineer this was for a
full-time sort of sashaying opportunity
and so the expectation by the company
was that I'd be there for a long time
and so they invested a lot uh in their
in their employees
and one of the interesting opportunities
I had was working on the retail floor
doing sales for a month and this is
called home by kinshu so sales training
where I was selling uh digital video
cameras digital cameras and other
electronics so kind of a rich experience
and
during this time I also came across Joy
ito's blogs maybe some of you have heard
of his name before he's the currently
the MIT media lab director but at the
time he's also known for I think
launching one of Japan's first isps
and I started to notice some
similarities of course he's a bit older
but he was a Japanese who grew up in
North America I was an American who grew
up in Japan at the age of 14 we both
moved back to our home country and
finished off high school so I went to
boarding school in the U.S
we were both interested in music and
technology and so I kind of looked up to
him and and I wanted to learn more about
him and eventually had an opportunity to
meet him on a panel and invited him to
speak uh at Sony on sort of Internet
Trends and Technologies
so
um Richard mentioned that Howard
Stringer became uh CEO towards the end
of my stint at Sony and so I started I
moved to a different division there but
during the sort of the latter half of my
time at Sony
um there are a couple interesting things
happening so in 2004 uh Facebook and
green launched and Google ipo'd
in 2005
odesk and and Amazon's Mechanical Turk
also launched and then in 2006
uh Twitter launches and mixy IPOs and
mixes uh one of Japan's larger sort of
Social Network Services
so all this is kind of happening
um and I'm thinking you know I'd start
to sort of get the itch the bug and I
want to try to experience and maybe
potentially launch my own service
and so I left and decided to uh
um improve my sort of web development
knowledge and started majidis which just
kind of if you know Japanese kind of an
odd company name
um when you pick up the phone yes it's
it's for real it's basically what it
means
um and so
so it's kind of an umbrella company uh
where I launched a couple projects and
one of them was in the upper left you
see kidakidachi and it's kind of this
idea of bringing Hot or Not to Japan
that didn't work out so well
um around 2007 I guess late 2006
Nintendo launches their Wii console and
so I launched a service called me
station and this was sort of the Avatar
creation so if you've played with the
Wii before there's the me channel where
you can make your own caricature
and so this is a service where you
upload a photo of yourself and we would
make we'd sit in front of the TV and
make the Avatar character for you and
then send it to your Wii console and it
got some publicity and some PR managed
to get in the Wall Street Journal which
is kind of cool but the problem was was
not very scalable we couldn't reverse
engineer this and so the more orders we
got the more we were sitting in front of
a TV trying to make these caricatures of
other people
uh and so another service I launched uh
is this nicorable we're focusing more on
the scalability and getting people to
contribute to the platform by creating
their own sort of a b polling uh sort of
service
and during this time of course I'm doing
some client work on the side that's what
I actually paid the bills and uh the
English-speaking community in Tokyo is
pretty small and so I eventually met my
co-founder Rob
who had moved back to Japan
um a couple a couple months before I had
met him and his wife is Japanese he met
her in London and so uh as he was trying
to navigate uh Tokyo he was kept asking
his wife to to translate uh content so
he could you know read news and and blog
posts and whatnot
and so as we started working on a couple
projects together he's got a design
background and I've got the systems
background so there's a good pairing
um I hear this frustration that he has
around translation and I immediately
recalled uh when I was back at Sony
towards the end of my uh stint there
even though I was hired as an engineer I
was regularly asked to translate a lot
of content for my colleagues and this
was either emails email correspondence
um articles that they wanted to
understand better even Internal
Documentation which seemed kind of odd
to me at the time
um you know that they would be asking
just because I was bilingual uh that
they would be asking me to translate so
we eventually launched gengo so I'm
going to explain a bit about the
business
and then I'll get into sort of the
fundraising and all and all that that we
also went through so
basically it's a human crowds for human
translation platform where we
crowdsource individuals from around the
world uh
and because of the infrastructure that
we've built we're able to provide
translation at a significant cost
savings to sort of the traditional
industry
um and we believe it's about a 33
billion dollar market and growing
um the
part of the market that is most
applicable for us is is a portion of
that but we we believe it's growing
because a lot of this content did not
even exist eight to ten years ago
because of uh Facebook and Twitter uh
and large e-commerce platforms that are
growing so some of our clients
um
include trip advisors we do a lot of the
hotel reviews uh Rock 10 which is uh
Japan's largest e-commerce platform and
uh YouTube the the video the captions on
the videos for them
so we're predominantly in in two
locations Tokyo
um where our largest team is in San
Mateo uh where it just came from this
morning and we've done about close to 90
million dollars in funding so
when we first started
it was a real simple order form and this
is all we had
copy and paste and upload some text
upload a file uh you immediately get a
quote if you're translating from English
uh or sort of word-based languages then
we just calculate how many words in the
document and we charge per word if
you're translating from Chinese or
Japanese or other character based
languages then we just calculate the
number of characters uh and then you
just pay on the spot and you wait for
the translation to come back so real
simple process kind of made trans
translations a more of a transaction
based interaction
and as we looked at the content coming
into the system uh we noticed in
particular there were a lot of user
reviews
a lot of restaurant listings a lot of
hotel reviews a lot of short form
content basically a lot of user
generated content
uh and sure enough if you look at the
spread more than half of the type of
content we do is under 500 Words
so we noticed that it turns out an API
integration is really something that
makes sense for platforms that have this
high volume of short form content so an
API
uh you know allows sort of Integrations
of systems to simplify the flow and
ordering of translation
and so we after we launched the order
form we noticed this trend in the type
of content we we sort of rejiggered it
and turned it into an API to allow other
platforms to integrate and we now have a
couple
um
examples some these are some of the
highlights and so
pixel on the left is a sort of like a
Japanese version of Shutterstock so
Shutterstock is a US listed
multi-billion dollar company where they
just
sell photos it's like a photo library
and you've got titles and labels and
photo descriptions and so we help
translate a lot of those and pixel
wanted to go Global pretty early on and
so we helped translate a lot of this
content into English and simplify
Chinese complex Chinese
vestier is an interesting startup out of
France and they are a platform that
helps resell uh use luxury clothing so
you've got your expensive jacket or your
shoes you never want to you don't want
to wear anymore still a high value item
and so the seller types the description
in French and puts it in a package and
sends it off to the Paris office and I
had an opportunity to go visit they've
got this seven step process where they
validate and check that it's not a fake
and make sure it's clean and all that
and if it's all good then they package
it and they flip a switch and that turns
the item first on for sale and that
triggers in their system the sending of
the French original French description
through the API to our platform and our
translators will grab the text and
translate it into English and then when
they click submit it gets sent back to
the of SDR system and that's now it's
available for the English-speaking
Community to buy as well and so creates
a lot more liquidity for vastier
and the cus the sellers are happy larger
audience the customer is happy they have
access to more products and we also have
a YouTube integration where if you
upload a video with captions
uh the you'll you'll see sort of a
button that says translate this and then
you choose your target languages and
those get sent through the API our
translators look at the video uh and
they translate the the captions and when
they're done uh they click submit and it
gets sent back to YouTube and now the
video is available with captions in
other languages as well
so the cool thing about having an API
integration though is we can handle the
um sort of volatility volatility uh of
of the content as it comes in so on
average for example the vestier example
uh vestir integration they're doing
about four to five hundred jobs a day
but at Peak time so maybe some kind of
holiday or something
um they might they would send over a
thousand of these descriptions which
most you know a traditional translation
agency would not be able to handle that
sort of flow
so how do we actually manage uh the
translators
this is really core to to our platform
uh and it starts with an internal team
we call Tops or the translator
operations team it's about four
individuals and they are tasked with for
each language pair that we support
hiring a senior translator and that
senior translator is responsible for
their language pair and they create
tests they manage they evaluate the
tests and they are sort of like a
moderator for the for the language pair
and as we advertise on a platform like
Facebook for individuals who are
bilingual who are interested in working
on Gango we've managed to get about 10
000 translators who have passed and
qualified uh to become a Gango
translator now the testing is pretty
difficult if you're a bilingual yourself
you're welcome to give it a try don't
get upset with me if you don't pass but
there's over a hundred thousand
individuals who've tried so less than 10
percent actually become a Gango
translator it's pretty challenging
uh but it's really important for us to
to nurture this base of translators
and so we create a lot of materials uh
for translators to to sort of work uh
and improve and work up the system so
um over 50 of individuals on our of the
translators on our platform are not uh
professional translators they're
bilingual individuals some of them are
many of them are students
um
and so there's uh they're not as
familiar with some of the translator
tools
um aspects around time management
they've never really worked freelance
before and so we create documentation
for them uh to educate them
um under these uh under these topics so
you've got the the art of revision
um making text sound natural of course
language is a living thing right and so
um how do you translate new words new
terminology how do you stay with pop
culture and how does that you know
translate uh pun intended to another
language right so
um we we this is really important for us
so once you become a translator
you get access to a dashboard
and on this dashboard is when the jobs
come in it's a first come first serve
system
so uh you have to be pretty quick
um but there's a lot of flexibility
flexibility you can choose which jobs
you want to do you can look at how long
it's going to take you can see how much
content there is that you're going to
have to translate so you can sort of
adjust with the available time that you
have in the day
and we also try and be very transparent
about how our system is evaluating the
translators uh and so I mentioned the
senior translators they have internal
tools themselves for spot checking and
evaluating the translation output from
each of these translators and before it
goes back to customer a senior
translator will check it and give it a
score
and so we reveal uh sort of the
translator's reputation in the system to
each individual translator so they can
see their quality and of course speed is
also really important most of our
customers are trying to sell something
online they're trying to get out to an
audience as quick as they can uh and so
the translators start to get accustomed
to uh sort of balancing this this
quality versus speed
and there's sort of a nice equilibrium
so overseeing all of this is that tops
team that I mentioned and their focus is
on sort of three pillars their speed
quality and scale and a number of
parameters go into each one
uh and what we've done is is created
this sort of language pair Health index
which is kind of like a GDP for a
language pair and so there's like a all
these parameters get put into some
equation and outcomes in a single number
and if that number gets below a certain
threshold then we know there's a problem
for that language pair and the tops team
goes in and tries to figure out which of
the parameters are actually impacting it
in a negative way and they try and fix
that fix that issue and and bring the
number above threshold again
so
um that's kind of a a pretty cerebral or
analytical way of how we manage the
crowd
of course we're talking about humans
and uh one of the ways that we give them
uh each individual translator are sort
of more public faces we feature them on
our blog
and so I just want to introduce a couple
of of the translators so uh for example
we have Muhammad he's uh translates from
English to Arabic he's based in Egypt
and what's interesting about him is he's
actually a chemist by day he has a
chemistry YouTube channel uh but by
night he likes to do translation
we've also got rajaha uh he's in Nigeria
and he has a German uh studies
background a degree in German studies
and so he translates from English to
German
so for a bit more insight we asked them
to share with us sort of their work
environment
and so here's rajaha's sort of computing
environment apparently he has rather
unstable uh power grid and so sometimes
he has to go to the cafe
um
here's one the environment that Muhammad
Works in
and where he also records his his
chemistry YouTube channel uh and so it's
important for us to understand sort of
the environments that these translators
also work in because it drives and
directs uh our product development
um not everyone has a has a large screen
some of them work on mobile not everyone
has a has a desktop computer and so
there's different changes that we have
uh to take into consideration
so to give you a sense of the volume
that we're doing on average we're doing
about two and a half million words a
week now this fluctuates quite a bit
sometimes we'll just do a million
sometimes we'll do it over five uh and
so the API the infrastructure that we've
built allows us to handle this very
volatile uh these swings uh in the
volume that comes in
we're doing about 248 words of
translation per minute uh just for frame
of reference the fastest typer in the
world uh can type at 216 words per
minute so
um it's pretty fast a little over 10
percent of our translators are actually
active in any given week
and we're currently doing about 56 uh
language pairs
so we've been doubling in the volume of
work that we've been translating per
year and we expect to do that again this
year
um it says here units that's sort of our
kpi or uh the the metric that we uh
measure that we really look at in detail
to see how we're how we're growing uh
and so I mentioned a unit is either a
word or a character depending on the
source language
so we've been doubling since launch so
that's where we are uh now and we've got
about
uh yeah a little over ten thousand uh
lay translators we call them now we're
investing a lot in quality and
Technology uh and we can't basically
have two types of customers we've got
the web so the individuals who go online
I'll show you a link towards the end you
can um get some free credits and try out
a translation if you'd like order a
translation for free
and we also have our API customers or
the sort of high volume Integrations
uh but it took quite a bit to get here
uh and when we first started uh for the
first eight months I was sleeping on an
inflatable mattress uh at home and I
didn't really know how these mattresses
worked and so for the first one I slept
on I would wake up every morning and I
would be lying on the floor because all
the air had escaped and I just figured
that's how you wake up it turns out
there was a hole in their mattress which
I discovered a few months later
um so uh and to keep costs low I you
know kind of sold a bunch of my uh
things I didn't really need
um and I wasn't since I wasn't really
sure where this was going I didn't
really want to invest in sort of a new
apartment and all this kind of stuff and
so I was fortunate to have sort of a
space my parents place for a couple
months
um and this was kind of nice because uh
I ended up saving money on my commute so
I would just walk to the office and back
home in about 45 minutes which was
actually kind of good because it forced
me to get some amount of exercise
obviously I'm sitting in front of the
computer all day and so having to walk
home is not such a bad idea
um also gave me time to think uh and
solved some problems in my head as I'm
sort of walking back and forth
so we raised a small friends and family
round
and managed to move into this is our
first shared office
uh just a cubicle and sort of
a shared office space where there are a
lot of artists and and architects
I think we're one of the few internet
groups doing some internet stuff and
as we were building the business and and
winding down the client work that we
were doing
um
I started to think you know
should we be moving to the Bay Area
should we you know is this something
that we can continue doing in Japan
and
um thought maybe we can try and bring a
piece of Silicon Valley to Tokyo
thinking that this idea behind Silicon
Valley is more a mindset uh versus like
a physical you know knee or location and
so
um more of an attitude and so we tried
raising Capital uh in Tokyo we were
introduced to a number of Angel
Investors both uh wealthy foreigners and
Japanese in the area and
um it was kind of it was a challenge we
even pitched to a digital garage which
was Joey ito's investing firm
um and they're known for bringing like
uh LinkedIn and and Twitter to to Japan
uh and we even applied to some
competitions
um that some companies were running with
Awards of about a hundred thousand uh
dollars of equivalent value
um but for some odd reason a lot of
these competitions were behind closed
doors and so we don't no one really
knows who won or
um what not so it's kind of this is back
in 2008 2009 so
um that's sort of the the environment
that that we were in and
um nothing really kind of it was very
difficult to raise and so we started to
sort of look outside of Japan
and back in 2006 when I after I left
Sony I spent some time doing a bit of
networking trying to meet individuals to
build up a client base and I was
introduced to Dave McClure uh who's
known for building up 500 startups he's
the VC there
and his wife is actually Japanese and so
he was coming to Japan on vacation and
I'd met we kind of kept in touch and I
shared it with him the me station and
the and the kiraki and the Nico these
web services that I was building and
um when when we were working on Gango I
kind of reached out to him and said hey
we're working on this what do you think
and turns out he was going to be in
Tokyo and so we had an opportunity to
pitch to him and uh by the end of the
pitch he had opened up his laptop and he
said look I'll give you uh I'll make a
small investment but I want you to come
out to the Bay Area and meet a bunch
individuals I'm going to introduce you
to and try and close the seed round
uh and so we got really excited and a
month later uh in January 2010 we flew
out here Rob and I uh that's Dave in the
middle
and over about 10 days we did over 30
presentations uh it's a lot of driving
up and down I was doing all the driving
Rob was working on the pitch deck and
the passenger seat
um and very interesting and exciting
period for us and a few months later we
managed to close our seed round
in part through some nice PRN visibility
that we got so we had some friends who
were journalists in Japan
representing either foreign us-based
media such as TechCrunch
and also tapped into my network uh when
I was at Sony and managed to get some
visibility in Japanese press as well
so after securing that first seed round
we moved into
a larger office and wanting to again
sort of bring that piece of Silicon
Valley to Tokyo of course how to get
some bean bags uh and we had company
colored bean bags so blue and orange at
the time our we went through rebranding
so our design sense is a little
different now
um and we were in this space for a
couple years uh but about a year after
in this same space it turned into
something like this
so we grew pretty quick it got pretty
packed in there uh but uh very exciting
we're now in a slightly larger office
so just to get into the fundraising
aspects I sort of thought about the
different fundraising stages that we
went through and put together some
observations so our seed round we went
through two seed rounds
and the investors in those were either
Japanese who
um were living or had lived overseas or
foreigners who were in Tokyo
or individuals with a very International
background and so
um the early seed round investors all
sort of understood this challenge we
were trying to solve around translation
and the need with the sort of this
International Global Connection
the series a round was pretty
challenging uh to raise there was a lot
of local interest uh but most of the VCS
uh in in Japan were only really focused
on Japan and couldn't think sort of
outside of Japan for this stage of the
fundraising
uh there was a lot of U.S interest
but the there was already a lot of good
deal flow around here and so to there
was not um they weren't quite ready to
take the plunge and invest outside of a
sort of their local area
but we were very fortunate to meet
atomico the uk-based VC founded by
Nicholas stenstrom one of the Skype
co-founders
and they have a mission of uh having
global Investments and so we really
connected they're also very product
driven uh VC and so uh as as are the
founders Rob and I very sort of really
into the product and so
I mean connected and they helped lead
our series a our series B round which we
closed earlier last year
um there are not so many uh Japanese
species that have gone through this
stage of investment from my experience
and so our options are few again there
was good U.S interest uh but
um there's the fact that we wanted to
stay Rob and I want to stay in Japan
seem to be
um a difficult sort of point to get over
uh partly also because it's difficult
for the US VCS to exercise their Network
and their resources in a space that they
may not have an office for example so
but we're very fortunate to raise from
Intel they obviously have a very large
existing Global footprint and they saw
us as an asset to their portfolio of
other Investments that they've made
so in addition to the challenges in the
fundraising uh the other biggest
challenge that we've had is has been in
hiring so this is a recent photo of our
team
and about once every seven or eight
months we bring everyone together so we
fly the US team over to over to Japan uh
and get together and and do sort of a
mini conference we call gen conference
uh it's about a couple days and in this
photo there's about I guess 12 13
different nationalities being
represented so very diverse team uh in
the Tokyo office and in the in the San
Mateo office
um
but I think the some of the challenges
sourcing so when we first started
um because there aren't so many startups
there are not very many individuals who
have startup startup experience uh and
loyalty so
um The Challenge around loyalty a lot of
uh employees in the sort of Japanese
employment environment very loyal to uh
their employer and so it's hard to move
them uh there's not a whole lot of
mobility and in The Hires that we've
done we've basically learned to expect
that it could take anywhere from three
months to six months before someone who
has agreed to join us can actually move
uh and join us and and that's pretty
long
um
I think
and flexibility in the contracts and so
um I mentioned the session concept
Japanese company is really investing in
in their employees and there's this it's
very hard to uh
uh sort of change your team structure
and as a startup you need a lot of that
flexibility you might have to Pivot you
need to try things out not everyone is
the right sort of fit depending on it
sometimes it can take time to learn if
it's the right kind of fit and so
um we've sort of structured it where all
of our contracts are fixed term and that
comes with a bit of a premium we might
have to change our compensation package
a little bit
um but those are some of the the
challenges that we've had to come to
learn
but I think the environment's getting a
lot better so this is Sky Tree if under
construction I haven't actually had a
chance to go visit it yet but um it's
supposed to be quite nice so when we
first started uh there are not very many
sort of incubators or accelerators so
not the environment in supporting this
idea of prototyping and building new
Services
was still uh pretty non-existent
um
employees mostly had very low risk
profile
and there are limited sources for
funding but now uh even just in Tokyo
they're I've calculated over at least 15
incubators type operations and some of
these are individually run some of these
are corporate run incubators
in uh in Japan it's it's kind of sexy
it's kind of cool to be doing a startup
uh and there's even these weekend events
um where teams get together and try and
produce an idea
and since it's been
you know about five years now there's
there have been a couple startups uh
that others between which
um employees have sort of moved around
and so there's been a bit more mobility
and some more experience in sort of the
the worker uh the employee pool
um and I think
there's been more sort of example
startups uh and a smarter sort of
investor pool and much better sort of
information exchange between the Bay
Area and and Japan so there's
um you know I'm obviously a flag between
Tokyo and and the Bay Area pretty
regularly
um there's many others who do the same
the incubators out here like Y
combinator and 500 startups provide sort
of a short-term period for uh
entrepreneurs in in Japan to come out
here and experience and see what it's
like and expose himself to this
environment before they go back it's a
lot more cross-pollination in that
information
has been really great for the ecosystem
in Tokyo
so this is should be an intersection
um and sort of my assessment real sort
of uh back of the napkin uh assessment
it kind of looks like this there's I'm
just listening a couple of the
incubators and I guess these slides will
be shared so you can check them out a
little later there are a number of
promising startups now and a couple of
these have actually moved out here
um for one reason or another
and if you're interested in learning
more about this space
uh there's some interesting resources
that are gathering a lot more
information and these are all in English
and some of them are using gengo to
translate for uh other languages such as
Indonesian uh and Chinese to reach their
Asian three-station sphere
I think there's still some areas of
improvement and this may just be a
matter of time
one is exits and mentorship so we're
starting to see some more startups
ipoing in in Japan
and and a couple Acquisitions but not at
the volume that you see out here or in
some other environments but I think
that's improving
uh I do believe in my sort of
observation there's a little bit of a
retention issue around the mentors and
so I've there are a number I'm not going
to mention names or anything but there
are a number of uh successful Japanese
entrepreneurs who have had wonderful
exits and they've ended up moving out
here to the Bay Area After exiting in
Japan and I wish they would sort of give
back a little bit more to the local to
the Japanese economy and Mentor there
um
another area of improvement so
a bit need a bit more flexibility in
workspaces particularly temporary
workspaces uh and workplace regulations
so by this I mean if you want to rent a
office space in Tokyo there's uh still a
lot you have to give up you have to
guarantee uh
almost your life if you want to just
rent a place there's a lot of background
checking that goes on and it's a very
tedious and and basically egregious
process and I think it could be a lot
easier
um
and large organizations
don't seem to yet really know how to
work with startups and this probably
exists in other places as well but in
Japan
um it's it's pretty challenging and and
they might think it's novel but
um there's a lot of extra meetings that
need to happen you know relationship
building is important but as a startup
you need to have the flexibility to be
able to move quickly and so this has
been a challenge for some
and the government is investing more in
these funds to help startups one in
particular is tasked with helping
startups in Japan Go Global and go
overseas
however uh the management of that fund
does not speak any English so it seems
kind of odd to me and it kind of
questions how serious they really are
about these kinds of efforts uh and so
potential areas of improvement
this is our San Mateo office we make
every effort to make sure that the
distance uh does not become a barrier
for us
we do regular sort of video conferencing
and and
meetings like this of course there's a
time zone challenge but between the west
coast and Tokyo it's it's not that bad
um and so a couple takeaways what's sort
of helped us grow just making sure that
this separation is not uh you know it
doesn't hinder Us in any way
um I think we've been pretty fortunate
in getting to know the local reporters
of foreign media so we've had some great
coverage and visibility and I think if
you're thinking of doing a startup
in an environment where you can build
these kinds of relationships you should
take every Advantage you can
um also appealing to reporters of local
media obviously we're helping Japanese
businesses go International Go Global
and so we've tried to emphasize on this
story
the ecosystem startup ecosystem in Tokyo
it's uh it's pretty tight still and it's
very important to support each other and
so we've done a lot of partnering and
working with other local entrepreneurs
either through an event to gather
interesting talent for hiring or just
cross marketing cross promotion and also
focused on finding these sort of
entrepreneurs if you will in Enterprise
so this idea of of working at a startup
it's becoming more accepted uh and there
are but there are still some individuals
in large corporations who are tempted by
it but are not quite ready to to take
the plunge but they want to work with uh
with other startups and so if you can
identify that individual in that company
then I think you'll have an easier time
working with that large Enterprise
so that's basically my story
um thanks for listening uh if you want
to try out gengo if you go to gingo.com
try you'll get some free credits
and you can follow the company Twitter
feed at gangawit so thanks
so Matt I want to just be clear gengo is
using only human translators you don't
have machine translation back in the
back of this yeah okay okay and are you
still able to be faster
than say what would come out of so our
turnaround time calls actually for those
of you who don't know Japan's had
commercial machine translation software
for 20 years now yeah
yeah so machine translation is always
going to be faster
um we have managed to reduce our
turnaround time to it depends on the
length but to minutes and so we have
customers who are ordering Twitter feeds
and short blog posts
um and they'll get it back with them and
that includes the from the time they
place the order through gingo until the
translation actually comes back that's
correct so what um there's sort of two
parts that affect the the turnaround
time one is how quickly it gets picked
up by a translator and the other is how
quickly they can actually do the
translation yeah and so that first part
you can squeeze to near zero uh and so
that's one of our focuses and the other
part we try and improve through
technology and the interface that
translators use yeah okay
um why don't I open the floor
questions
all right so that's a great story and
it's terrific that you're doing it in
Japan I guess the butt that follows this
I didn't catch why there would be a
business advantage to having it in Japan
you can raise the money in Japan the
problem with the facility so on is there
any are there any advantages were there
advantages from actually doing in Japan
other than that's where you wanted to do
it and I think it's terrific but cool
yeah it's a good question I mean at this
point we sort of say that our
headquarters is online doesn't really
matter where we are
um one of the interesting things that we
have found uh with respect to hiring
Talent is that in Japan there were able
to offer an environment uh that appeals
to individuals outside of Japan and in
Japan but particularly outside Japan who
have really great skills but that larger
company is like a Google or Facebook
cannot offer typically you kind of want
to be uh you know at the at the heart of
the company at the at the headquarters
right and so for the big tech companies
uh that's out here but for us it's
actually in Japan and so we're able to
find individuals who you know with great
engineering backgrounds interested in
working in Japan and that helps us being
in Japan sort of a competitive Advantage
if you will
in that sense
okay
uh you're you have a translators all
over the world
um what is a mechanism you use to pay
your translators and hand you women to
any issues with the national laws
regarding vaccine is there any kind of
contractors but some countries don't
permit independent contractors so how of
you have you encountered that whole
environment the regulation of employees
and so forth sure yeah good question so
there are definitely some countries
where we're not allowed to do business
and we make sure that the translators
are not working in that country
North Korea for example right
we use PayPal basically for paying out
our translators and so if I if uh
translator is able to make an account
um in you know PayPal account then we
just sort of send the funds uh to to
them to their account there
uh that's
basically
um can I ask a couple more details sure
basically base it in dollars or is it
the day's exchange rate or how do you
how do you yeah so all the translator
payments are done in dollars uh and so
it's kind of up to the the onus is on
the translator to convert it to their
local currency if needed
um there are ways that we could improve
that experience of course
um and eventually uh when our product
team you know there's always a backlog
of developments
yeah so you know address that but okay
um yeah go ahead Ethan
where do so one of the problems brought
up was uh helping each other more and uh
and supporting each other where do most
Japanese startup Founders and employees
meet is it in other words what type of
meetups what type of events draw them
and bring them together that's a good
question so
um there are a couple events that uh are
sort of run by popular services that
originated outside Japan so GitHub for
example has their drink ups and their
drink UPS in uh in Tokyo
um and I'm just kind of thinking about
Tokyo specifically um just because
that's where we're based I'm sure some
of this happens in like Fukuoka or other
parts of Japan as well
um there's The Hacker News meetups those
happen occasionally uh there are
um sort of development language focused
meetups uh such as cook pad runs a ruby
uh Meetup because that's their core
system language
other companies like the kddi lab they
have an opportunity I think it's at
least once a month for startup Founders
to sort of present and so kddi provides
a space for that kind of event and so if
you go to services like P ticks for for
example is like an event service if you
go to like an event right or something
you'll start to see and and door Keepers
and other ones a very local event
service but
um they're I think Founders companies
and sometimes Founders themselves are
getting better at
um you know running a uh an evening
event to get that Community together
yeah
foreign
so among the people who have an interest
in entrepreneurship are you seeing a lot
from University students in Japan
um I do occasionally run into University
students
um I have not seen and it could just be
me but I have not seen sort of services
built by uh University students I do
know that one of the is I think it's
Infinity Ventures which is one of the
funds in Tokyo does run an event just
for University students
which I have not attended but yeah okay
go ahead
company
zombies and the boy now everything
great you know and uh careful now your
time isn't as a balance in it or
my question is
has it impact our service
so we've been all very aware of the
level of of customer support and Service
uh that's just fantastic in Japan and we
try and and live up to supporting that
having that kind of uh service and
support for our customers as as well
um and we have a great uh customer rep
support head who is always thinking
about how he can wow uh customers and
it's kind of call it's called the wow
campaign but
um basically if anything ever goes wrong
or if there should ever be a challenge
that customers go through always trying
to go above and beyond and and uh and
satisfying them so it's a core part of
our service
I would have been um
yeah
so I'm glad you brought that up um
because that we've seen a number of
interesting stories where our
translators
um they are really passionate about uh
uh the work that they do and so
oftentimes they'll go above and beyond
and do some more research uh and
um include that in the translation as
they give it back to the customer so
there we've seen some cases of content
about a historical figure
um and the translator actually do some
research and provide some context about
that individual uh and because
oftentimes it might be something that
you might not you would not find on on
Wikipedia uh in in the original in your
target language for example so our
translator is really passionate about
um and because they have the flexibility
to choose what jobs they do they usually
pick the ones that are of personal
interest to them as well and so they'll
go above and beyond in that context
um I would say I mean what we've done is
made the the process a lot easier and
smoother so there's always in our in our
infrastructure it's ultimately it is the
individual it is a it is a person who is
involved and so
um I haven't seen it but let me ask you
a follow-up because I remember in
reading some of the materials on the
gingo website right you've got a process
for spot checking and peer review to
make sure that you know the translation
quality is good I mean it's great to say
that you know it's good on average but
that one percent of of things that would
be a problem would be a killer if
somebody's depending on the translation
right so how do what tell a little bit
about how you check for Quality how do
you do that sure so um we have uh
internal tools that
um the senior translators use to
evaluate the content that comes through
and basically if it's a new translator
that each each individual a translator
has to build sort of a reputation or a
profile and so translators who are new
to the system uh get checked more
regularly and as they build up a good
reputation then we don't have to look
after them as much and so that helps us
basically scale out do they know how
each other's reputation is
um not currently uh so that may be one
difference between this and say the
Linux development Community where you
have a lot of uh you know programmers
who are coding and everybody knows who's
really good and who's sort of so I'm
glad you brought that up because that's
actually the direction that we're going
in and we've already seen a number of
our translators I showed you that
dashboard where you have the quality and
the speed we have translators who take a
screenshot of that and put it on their
Facebook and so they want their
community and their connections to see
how they're doing yeah and so just
making that process even easier is is
going to be the next phase for us okay
yeah
following the same thing do you
purposely try to recruit translators in
particular domain expertise and medicine
or engineering or
biology okay
um we have done some targeted
recruitment for a certain type of
content but not at that level so just to
be clear the type of content that we're
best at is sort of user generated
content that
regular individuals should be able to
understand so the special specialist
content that you've mentioned like
medical patents like really deep Tech we
actually partner with agencies that have
that kind of expertise and if we see
that content come in we'll send it off
to those agencies we don't actually do
them at the high volume that we would do
product descriptions user reviews
Twitter feeds so we're seeing a lot of
things like Lady Gaga's tweet feed or
Justin Bieber's tweet feed it's like
that kind of sort of user generated
content that didn't really exist uh you
know eight to ten years ago is is the
bulk of of what we Translate
yeah
um I'm just wondering
um how the relationship between
translators and the customers Works in
terms of how deep is that relationship
do they have the ability to talk to each
other or is it just that they receive a
document and they send off a document is
there the option for repeat translations
from a certain translator if you like
the work they've done great question so
the customers and translators do have
the ability to have a discourse and
communicate and oftentimes there's some
clarification that the translator wants
from the customer
um but that's kept Anonymous and so
um we've seen we saw earlier on uh
customers ordering love letters and and
the type of content that you might be a
little embarrassed to ask a friend to
translate for example
um or someone that you know and so we we
maintain uh anonymity across between
customers and translators but they're
able to ask questions and and have
communication
um yeah
better
curious uh since many Japanese a
government or Enterprise try to start
this encourage entrepreneurship since
you are a success example has any of
those organizations approached you use
you as an example to show them the ropes
we have been fortunate enough to be
featured in the media
um I'm not we have some conversations
with uh some of the government funds
that I mentioned um towards the end uh
um but we have some
um we're still trying to figure out how
to manage that relationship so we
haven't really been sort of a marquee uh
example yet
um and we're still trying to grow the
business and so I think it's it's still
a little bit early for us to say it's a
complete success let me ask a kind of
delicate question because your funding
comes from an International Group are
you considered an a foreign affiliate
firm in Japan
what's the status of the company
so we were founded in Japan which is a
really core piece of our story if we
were not in Japan we probably would not
have had this this idea and this need
and so that's
um that's the message that that's really
important I think for the for the
community okay okay
so I think right now a huge Advantage
your your service has over machine
translations that the accuracy and how
natural it sounds like that the
translation is so
um we know the capacity for algorithm to
process large data and it's increasing
exponentially so let's assume two years
down the road and machine a translation
can almost as be as accurate as human
translation how would you respond to
that impact to your business
um so we see machine translation as more
of a complement than sort of a
competitor to us so language is a very
living uh sort of thing or organism if
you will uh and so
um there's always going to be new new
words new Concepts new phrases slang
that comes up and I think there's always
going to be an element that humans need
to be involved and so if machine
translation there may be at some point
an opportunity for us to provide machine
translation as an initial step for a
customer and maybe the customer wants to
um
improve on on that copy and somehow and
make it more unique uh so one of the
trends that we've seen is uh some of the
bigger search engines
um in particular Google for example can
identify if content has been machine
translated uh and so they actually are
able to mark Pages as okay this has been
machine translated so it's less original
and so they sort of reduce the ranking
and so that's why we're starting to see
customers that have large volumes of
content come to us because we provide a
competitive advantage and some
originality to to the content so
um it's I'm not to answer your question
we would
um sort of provide it as a as an
additional service and potentially
improve the speed that our translators
would be translating at
so you've scaled up really quickly but
other than the scale now what kind of
barriers of Entry are there to other
groups who would want to try to do the
same kind of platform
I think the education piece is really
important for us and the way we
communicate with our community back to
the omotanashi yeah and and how
um we sort of nurture and and really
sort of build a relationship with them
um we are about to make a hire for it um
to grow our community management team
um and these are you know positions
solely responsible for working with the
translator Community uh and as the group
grows and there's there may be some
Specialties and that we start to support
maybe some different languages that are
a bit more unique
um so it's it's going to always be
important to okay for that Community
yeah good
that'll be true yeah I'm
I'm really looking at first in Japan so
I have uh
how do you think Japan is pretty speed
so you know because uh you're saying
um
money for the new U.S investor yeah so
how do I see Japanese
well I mean I think they we
've we actually have some uh Japanese
investors so NTT docomo for example is
an investor um who joined the B round
um I think the they are great for the
relationship building and and helping
operationally and build the business I
think the challenge has been for
um Japanese VCS to
um
sort of lead around and be very quick
about closing we've had some cases where
we've heard of some stories and and even
went through a small experience where um
you know we wanted to close around and
we really liked working with a
particular Japanese VC but it was going
to take three months before they could
make a decision and we needed to make a
decision you know in a few weeks and so
um the relationship was important enough
for us that we let them come in after
the official closing but
um
it was definitely I think if they can
improve the pace uh and I think they're
starting to see um this pressure uh
internationally as well um I think U.S
VCS are starting to uh apply some you
know be more compete sort of sense uh
put some more pressure competitive
pressure on the Japanese feces as well
as money from other parts of Asia such
as Chinese faces for example so yeah one
of the things I'm getting from your your
talk is how fast things have changed
really just since
2008-2009 if you were to start gengo or
something like gengo right now would you
have done something different at the
very beginning stage would you do
something very different than you did
last time
uh well there's a lot of variables in
that so yeah
um
I mean I think the
uh we could have been better in
um our
the frequency of our communication
um with uh either side so with potential
investors potential investors yeah
um we in the first year and a half two
years you know we came to the Bay Area
maybe once every six seven months or
something if we come even you know every
three months or something I think it
would have been
um better for us yeah I think that is is
one of the things that is still not
quite as
developed in Japan as it is here just
the kind of Unwritten traditions of
investor uh investe
kind of relationships For Better or
Worse right yeah I agree okay
go ahead
written translation have you considered
oral translation and why did you choose
written as opposed to all sure so like
interpretation uh yeah we um
in the beginning it was just it's just
easier to launch with a text-based uh
platform and if we do start to support
uh audio or oral-based um it might be
through a partnership I think there are
a couple of interesting Services out
there that are sort of capturing that
that space uh so it's it's crossed your
mind but it's one of the key things I
think in in building a startup and
building a company in the very beginning
is just this the it may sound cliche but
really just staying focused
um and we have had a tendency of
Building Services uh additional Services
um kind of a little a little too early
um before sort of the core product that
you know we were building had really
proven itself and so we ended up
shutting those down and
um the time that in cost we had invested
in that could have been applied better
and so that's one of the reasons why
we've just stayed focused on the text
for a while
okay
as prime minister Ave made a step
function difference if so in what way
um
um I suppose peripherally but I haven't
really sort of experienced it directly
in terms of awareness uh and
appreciation so one of the challenges
um in hiring
families invest it put a lot of money in
play for various groups organizations in
the government yeah so yeah I think it's
more just the person from my personal
exposure it's been more just through the
visibility and the awareness
and we are now able to use it more when
we want to hire uh local talent
sometimes it'll be a young individual
who says well my mom has never heard of
your company before or something like
that and it's just like okay we'll have
to go talk to parents and then sort of
appeal by uh you know stating that look
the government is is getting behind
greater entrepreneurship and and this is
a good thing and telling that kind of
story and so and having those data
points that abesan has
find my appointment which is
interesting I haven't seen any
difference
um
difference in well he's he's made a big
Initiative for the employment of women
which of course in Japan has been a
different culture I mean there's a uh
really cool uh incube shared office
space
um called hatch I think it's hatch kids
or hatch and the individual running that
built the Space up uh with a focus on
helping women who have kids who want to
build their own business and so there's
actually a nursery uh sort of next to
the the shared office space and he's
doing a great job in getting a lot of
great visibility and and Caroline
Kennedy went and visited and uh and it
was the ambassador of course to Japan
for the US and so
um
there's there is more of that but it's
you know it's it's Japan Japanese
culture it's taken some time uh but I
think it's it's in the right direction
so I want to follow up with part of that
is in your talk you talked a lot about
the importance of engaging with both
foreign media and local media how do you
think the media engagement because
that's not talked about too much when we
talk about entrepreneurship and I do
think media engagement probably is a is
one of those things that can be
extremely important to a company how has
gingo benefited from the media sure um
we've had opportunities to be on WBS
World business satellite which is a TV
uh Channel show that starts around 11 30
at night and their focus is on
highlighting
um sort of new businesses uh in Japan
um and I think uh with some of the
messaging that's coming out of the prime
minister's office and and the government
that the media in general are starting
to sense like okay well the government's
saying this like you know we're the
sources of these these startups these
these entrepreneurs uh and so I'm
running into more reporters and and
individuals from you know Nikkei
business and what and NHK and whatnot at
some of these events but of course the
one thing that doesn't scale is the
entrepreneur's time well yeah I mean do
you think that really would you
recommend entrepreneurs to pay close
attention to developing media
relationships is it worth the time or
I think um one way you can do it
efficiently uh is
uh we did this thing where when we moved
into our office so it's like changes
people like to highlight some
improvement or some kind of change and
so when we moved into our new office we
did sort of a press event and we said
hey we're Gango we're moved into a new
office and it coincided with the latest
fundraising
um and we invited all the media that we
could we could had connections with and
filled the room of about 30 or so and
and it led to some good press and PR and
so if you can sort of concentrate it in
sort of phases yeah then you also can
try and create this sort of momentum
okay yeah if you just sort of I mean you
also want to keep a drum beat so you do
want to do it regularly enough
um but not like once a year you know
that's a little bit you know two sparse
I think yeah yeah okay
what it doesn't
matter over there stores the importance
of the video account for instance
am I right yeah uh what why do you think
in a major of doing communication
why is it important yeah right
um well so we're still a pretty small
company and it's important I mean
culture is a really key part and as I
sort of showed I hope you got in the
photo like diversity is really important
for us and and so to to maintain that
message uh and you know because we are
still uh small everyone's sort of role
really impacts pretty heavily even
across offices
um and our marketing team uh even it's a
Global Marketing team but they do a lot
for the Japan Market as well and the
individual running that is actually
based out of our San Mateo office here
he's Japanese
individual who grew up in in America and
so
um he likes to live out here but he
comes to Japan pretty regularly as well
um and so
uh and then just sort of operationally a
lot of cross-functional activities that
that require that communication
um and you know there's a lot of things
that that emails just don't don't cover
that you can do much more quickly and
efficiently if you can just speak in
person and if you can see their face
even better uh right instead of just
over the phone all the time so
yeah other questions
oh sir yeah I may have missed it but how
did you come up with a name Genco and oh
what does it mean and how does that
relate to translations sure yeah it's a
mystery to me yeah no I should have
covered this earlier on right so Gango
means language in Japanese okay
um we actually started as uh my Gango uh
because we couldn't get the
domaingango.com
um and so this concept in Japan of sort
of adding my before a word is
um sometimes pretty popular it's like my
boom my Hashi like my own kind of thing
and so we just we figured we'd do uh my
Gango and then we had an opportunity to
to get the actualgango.com domain uh and
so we rebranded
um and dropped uh the my kind of like
Facebook drop the call
do you actually have a copyright or
rather a trademark on the name Gango
then uh not on the name just on the
brain
so so when you're raising the uh C spawn
you must already have some uh customers
and translators how did you grow to that
stage before you have any external money
coming in sure yeah it's kind of a
chicken and egg problem right on the
very beginning
um so we focused first on
um getting uh just English Japanese
language pair uh for which we had a
network of bilingual individuals who
volunteered to be our sort of original
translators
um
and uh so once we had a pool of five to
ten of these translators then we sort of
marketed online
and
um try to get some customers and and
that's so that's kind of how it kind of
started to grow yeah so we had to use
our sort of local our friend network uh
and because we were bilingual ourselves
in the very beginning
um you know we could do some of the work
we could sort of see what was being
ordered uh we could sort of step in and
and tweak the product if we needed to
because we could function as translators
ourselves yeah
so dog fooding the platform is really
important to us so actually continuing
to use it uh ourselves is one of the key
ways of improving a product and I think
that's really important for startups I
think you know you have to really be
regularly using your own service to
understand what the customers are going
through to improve it so so right now
Japan has kind of a bad reputation about
you know not being entrepreneurial
what do you think will change that
I think it's getting better
um I mean I mentioned uh some of the
improvements of the incubators the the
trans I mean the key one of the key
areas of improvement I think though is
sort of the it's very kind of bottom
heavy still a lot of interest and
excitement um around building prototypes
and building a business and
participating in a startup but not a lot
of mentorship and I'm I'm hoping that
um some of the very successful
individuals can give back more and I
think uh like mikitanisan the founder of
Rock 10 is has started his own event
called Jane I think it's called
um and maybe some more of those events I
think maybe so and sound from SoftBank
is going to be doing his own kind of
event eventually so
um yeah giving back from the mentorship
I think okay I think that's a good note
for us to call in into the formal
session we've got some we've got some
things out there one more question okay
go for it
competitors yeah so
um there are a number of sort of
translation agencies he's out there
um
and that you you can sort of order
online from there's no one that I really
know that's doing the volume that we're
doing at and that has a uh the API as
core to their business
um so in a way it's kind of and there
are some technology translation
technology platforms
um that don't have translators but help
translate content because they have some
software that translators use and then
the finding the translators is up to the
customer or something like that and so
um we're finding that a lot of our
competition is more just around uh that
mind share like customers who want to go
Global who want to translate stuff they
there's there's a lot of these
businesses that are very good in a
specific domain but they see them all
the same so it's kind of a marketing
challenge a little bit and that's one
area that we're trying to improve yeah
okay let's call them into the formal
session and go out have some
refreshments and get to talk more
informally thank you thanks